now I'm got the keys for that [ __ ] now
why is the door locked
why can't we just have the [ __ ] door
open prison isn't it
prisoners or not this systems do my
nuttin what it's doing is just screwing
up any chance getting anything done
efficiently and what's gonna be like we
do go into production and we are busy I
mean opening a locker like art for a
chopping board you know ladles because
they're not edged I mean what these guys
gonna do with a chocolate board Laurens
number six where's your box it's the
moment of truth time to get the knives
out chopping though yeah if we're gonna
make any money out of this kitchen my
brigade have to have the tools to do the
job for you be careful however dangerous
they may be feet bukata
next number
times like this I wish you guys were
just internet fraud not gun crimes got
Internet fraud I can have the whole
thing open every day
no one's here to try and play around
with knives I've seen anyone else
behaving as if they want to use the
knife for me miscellaneous and a knife
or anything that sticks to flopping
understanded in knives but in the
kitchen in this kitchen
I've got criminals not chefs one of them
Lawrence Gibbons has got a list of
convictions as long as my arm my first
things are robbing post offices okay
I went to Mel oh man I needed some money
going Holloway and he said when I was
your age all that robbing banks and when
I bought Reston arms in Category prison
on the moans oh man come up in the visit
any punch be starting a louse hey you
said 11:00 time to get cold did I
[ __ ] idiot the guy's 45 years of age
he's stuck in his ways and I've seen him
work bloody good I mean he can graft but
he has a temper me a big temple
guys taste as well don't the Guardian
Noah's tasting yeah for this business to
work all my brigade have got to become a
team but Lance can't seem to work
alongside Ren a Smith
not me
seriously come to my Charlie too much
what bottle if it's something you're not
Oh
did sigh Charlotte Oh
that numbers
sometimes when you work on a wing the
atmosphere changes and it's a very
subtle change it feels unsettled the
place can erupt a sometimes it's either
the slightest pieces
okay listen all stop arguing there
wanted it listens a big difference
between talking to each other and
shouting each other is talk just gonna
stuff for me that I grew up with but
mummy's the run a little tea house call
the cobweb teahouse professionals and
the only thing I ever wanted was either
carrot cake bagel tart or treacle tart
it was so delicious